and then so we had like a week off trash
taste and as soon as as soon as as like
that was like I guess announced yeah
Sydney was like we're booking something
we're booking something now fill up the
schedule this is this is our time now
and so uh fair enough so yeah we went
away with your side job kicked in
my marriage
I only have no excuse now like what are
you doing ah again [ __ ]
and uh so yeah we uh took a nice few
days off and then I don't know why
because I feel like with holidays
there's like there's like a perfect time
where I'm able to like recharge reset
everything I feel like that's a week I
need to take like a week off yeah in
order to like get like the grind back
you know get like the motivation to get
grinding again if it's like one or two
days I've noticed with like the YouTube
brines it's just it throws you off your
schedule or throws off like this
momentum that you have I don't know it's
really weird do you have like a schedule
every day I um now that I have like a
second Shadow and the streams and stuff
yeah I actually do yeah it was time gone
yeah okay first time it's almost like
it's a real job
it's weird having a schedule now just uh
just waking up and being like oh [ __ ]
I've got stuff I need to do and uh it's
it's weird this this has been a very
weird time for me guys I know I'm like
transitioning
transitioning I remember when I was just
like one channel is like more than too
much one Channel's too much and now it's
just about placing your efforts in the
right place you know you know but make
sure you're working on the things that
you need to be working on yeah yeah
absolutely yeah I don't know it's also
just
I I find it easier to work on things I'm
passionate on so when I'm passionate
when I'm passionate
then I find it hard to concentrate on
anything else so what happens to your
second Channel when you get like bored
of genshin just like did you disappear
all content vanishes
I just delete the channel I'm gonna do a
classic gig move and disappear
taking a break I'll see you guys when
they update the game yeah
like you know I haven't thought that far
ahead but maybe by the time this video
comes if I can't diversify it's it's
weird because like I'm like in my in the
back of my mind I'm like I know I need
to diversify I should make it
but also I'm just addicted to playing
gentian so I'm like either I either I
don't play it uh either I don't stream
it and play it or I stream it and play
it well you can't quit now because
you're literally the biggest gen
streamer on Twitch
I don't know I mean you're pulling some
pretty crazy numbers it keeps growing
right now the numbers
and they're like man this growth is
awesome and then they get to a point
like wait hold on I don't want to play
this game anymore can you guys still
stick around and they're like see ya
yeah
they're gone then everyone's like wait
why wait wait you weren't watching for
me
it's all good it's all good um
all your verse will release their next
game and then that's that's a that's
more free content so I'm still relate
I'm still waiting for the star rail
release yeah three of us yes thank you
for the next game thank you thank you
you don't like that Meme of like the guy
feeding the creation like thank you
foreign
well I guess uh do you want to do you
want to talk about your your achievement
then God yeah I feel weird I hate it
when you're like congratulate me
congratulations
as selfless as it was selfish
I did it because I wanted to do it yeah
yeah because I I'm not going to sit here
and be like dude I just wanted to do a
charity event this I just wanted to do
this and I was like oh wait this makes
perfect sense
like I feel like a lot of the times some
events come along you're like this just
makes way more sense it's going to be
more fun for everyone it's going to be
way better if it's not just for me yeah
yeah I mean because it's like oh you
know I I thinking back I'm like how
could it as I pretty explain what I did
yeah I was about to say it's probably
been a while I'm sure we should be
watching this no I cycled across
Hokkaido with Chris
um 750 kilometers or something whoa nice
over 500 Miles how much did you raise
you raised over
316 thousand dollars
[Music]
[ __ ] incredible I mean two things
that shocked me when I saw that tweet
about when you guys finished one was
obviously the amount of money raised
which is crazy yeah two the fact that
Chris survived well so you know
obviously spoiler alert Chris is going
to come on the podcast again so I'll
I'll talk about it mainly from like I
suppose my perspective and the stuff
that I was dealing with because right
I'll let Chris talk about the other
stuff oh how he dealt with this I mean
yeah you know Chris's credit on the on
later days Chris doing better than me
yeah I mean I was like powering through
the first few days I was doing great
Chris was having a miserable time yeah
yeah and then you know a lot of the time
of cycling and stuff like you learned
you learn a lot of things when you do it
days in a row like I feel like the shin
namikaido we didn't actually learn
anything about cycling no of course not
because you just do it and you're done
and like you can you can you could cycle
for a day with a [ __ ] bike and not know
like it's all of our seats and
everything was completely wrong we
learned how not to cycle yeah like the
number one comment on the on our cycling
special was like you guys know like your
seat was we didn't know no we did we did
we know nothing about it we're not
cyclists and you know like so like to
put it into perspective like the shin
namikaido uh the thing that we did was
like 75k yeah but we might as well have
done it on a tricycle yeah yeah yeah and
it was literally a clown bike yeah yeah
and like I think on average we were
doing 100 plus kilometer days like every
single day and it's like one day we did
like 65 but even then like the weather
conditions change the cycling system
right right right right because you guys
are up in the mountains and you know I
feel oh yeah it changes all the time
right and then I got this [ __ ]
backpack on my back so I I you know when
I I because the reason why this happened
I'm sure we'll talk about this even more
again when Chris comes on this yeah
Chris was you know lamenting to me about
how he wants to get fit and stuff and I
was like bet let's actually do something
like let's let's do something like let's
do something crazy yeah and I was like I
really want to go to Hokkaido again
because this is like your favorite place
in Japan I just love Hokkaido honestly I
think it's my favorite thing it's
awesome
I I wanted to do something that would be
pretty tough yeah so I thought that'd
cycle I again like on a map I think
about this I'm like 500 Miles like ah
easy I can do that because like
cycling is tough but ultimately if you
just wake up early it's not that hard
[Music]
wait wait wait wait wait wait no no what
I'm saying is well anyway can you expand
if you want to do site like cycling
cycling like you want to get places and
like actually do it good yeah you you
don't have to wake up that early so what
you're saying is secret to winning Tour
de France isn't about training
because cycling right what there is like
you can cycle and you can cycle at a
pace that pretty much uses like your you
don't go out of breath you don't really
use your muscles that much it's kind of
like your natural toasty yeah yeah you
just your natural pace that's
comfortable for you on Like A Flat Road
that'll get you to your place if you've
set a reasonable distance like yeah I
was gonna ask like with the majority of
the roads flat
ah well I mean I'm sure there were some
inclines yeah I mean sometimes you get
lucky and it'd be flat but then I mean
like I'm talking like because my only
other point of reference is the Shimon
Army kaido right yeah I mean there is
some brutal Hills I mean like you've
you've driven on the roads in Japan
right yeah sometimes the roads just
don't end yeah yeah and they go up like
there was the worst one we had a few
really bad ones but the worst one was it
was um seven kilometers just uphill
right
you can imagine yeah how long that took
and then it was like seven kilometers
downhill which is not [ __ ] epic in
life and then you're like this is the
best thing ever yeah because it just
does it literally just doesn't stop
right but it's crazy because like that
kind of like elevation it's like we
started at the ocean and as you're
you're climbing up at some points you
can see the ocean and you are crazy high
up right right I think it was like uh
there's like 500 meter incline yeah yeah
which is like crazy yeah that you can
just like bike up that I don't know I
learned a lot I learned that your bike
seat height matters a lot I had mine
um so because you have to oh dude as
well another thing that I guess that
would be fun to talk about
dude trying to get your bike like
transport it yeah it's a nightmare
really well because how do you how do
you oh yeah because I guess you bike on
a plane oh yeah I don't know this [ __ ]
how do you get a bike
okay so you can get a turns out it's not
that hard
um I this is just like check-in or yeah
is it just oversized luggage it's in
like the special luggage okay right so
you just like go up to the counter and
but you have to pack your bag which is a
nightmare yeah you have to pack the
bicycle
um like so Chris I was lazy and I bought
a bag that you just take the front wheel
off it's super [ __ ] easy you just it
comes off and then you strap everything
in place right and I think to get on the
plane a a recommended deflating the tire
so it doesn't pop yeah yeah I don't
think it'll actually like pop though but
I just did it anyway yeah yeah and then
you will shove it in a bag I'm vastly
overestimating this it took like an hour
to do this and you get oil everywhere
it's so [ __ ] I hate this and then you
just check it in and then the whole town
on the plane you're panicking because
you're like this is a carbon fiber bike
it's gonna break and it's like
everything's gonna [ __ ] go wrong
right it's [ __ ] terrible and even
then I like going back before that it's
like all right I don't I don't own
anything to cycle do you own anything to
cycle well not since the shimanometer
but we bought like the shittest
shittiest Amazon Basics yeah yeah yeah
yeah that was just like how cheap can we
go it was one day yeah I I still use
those pans when I'm on the room bike
because it's because it's still padding
on my ass
aren't the exercise bikes like really
well padded I mean they are but like you
know if you're on that thing for like an
hour or two which I usually am yeah then
like after a while you're just like [ __ ]
man look I've got no me on my arms all
right after a while it just like goes
directly to my bones and I'm just like
my pelvis is screaming yeah of course
you also like dummy thick back there
yeah I think it makes it worse though